hey guys it's Justine and it might look
like I'm at a racetrack right now but
I'm not I'm inside of a studio with the
two new Forza Motorsport cover cars
we've got the cadillacv series.r and the
Corvette e-ray I'm so excited
I partnered with Xbox to share something
really special with you the new Forza
Motorsport is coming out on Tuesday
October 10th and I had the incredible
opportunity to check out the cars that
are on the cover yeah those two cars
that you see right there here I am with
them in real life
the first force of Motorsport game was
released back in 2005 and the last one
was all the way back in 2017. so we
haven't had it all new Forza Motorsport
game in over six years this game has
been built from the ground up with an
overhaul of the physics for more
accuracy the beauty of the cars and
tracks there's a new Dynamic time of day
advanced car damage and real-time Ray
tracing on the track for even more
realistic gameplay this is the most
technically Advanced racing game ever
made and I cannot wait to play it now
before we get more into the new 2023
Forza Motorsport release I feel like we
should take a moment to look back at the
history of Forza and the iconic cars
that have defined this franchise
Forza Motorsport was first introduced in
2005 for the original Xbox setting the
stage for this groundbreaking racing
series with the first cover car the
Acura NSX this game featured over 200
Cars and focused on realistic physics
and handling which set it apart from its
arcade style competitors the second
installment we had Forza Motorsport 2.
this expanded the roster to over 300
cars and improved the graphics and
physics engine and on the cover was the
Nissan 350Z I'm not gonna lie back in
the day like the 350Z was the car of my
dreams Forza Motorsport 3 brought the
Audi R8 to the Forefront this mid-engine
Supercar was a symbol of European
engineering and it solidified forza's
status as a premier racing franchise the
game also entered produced a new rewind
function which would let you undo
mistakes and perfect your driving skills
the fourth game came out in 2011 and it
featured the Ferrari 458 Italia the game
included over 500 playable cars and
added Auto Vista mode allowing players
to explore their favorite vehicles in
stunning detail Forza Motorsport 5
graced us with the McLaren P1 on the
cover as a launch title for the Xbox One
this game showcased the console's
improved Graphics capabilities and
introduced the drivatar system which
used cloud computing to create a more
realistic AI opponent all of this was
based on players driving Styles and it
was really fun because sometimes you
would be driving and you would just see
one of your friends cruising by you I
would always text them and be like
you're driving recklessly in Forza right
now I just wanted to let you know you're
unhinged in 2015 Forza Motorsport 6 took
us back to America with the Ford GT a
legendary car with a rich racing
Heritage this installment also
introduced wet weather and night racing
adding new challenges and depth to the
gameplay the Porsche 911 GT2 RS was the
last car on the Forza Motorsport 7 cover
this High Performance Machine
represented the Pinnacle of German
engineering and was a fitting Choice the
franchise most ambitious enter yet and
that my friends brings us to today after
six years of waiting let's check out
some gameplay of the new Forza
Motorsport
[Music]
obviously with the power of the Xbox
series X and Series S consoles we'll be
getting significant Graphics
improvements and taking full advantage
of Ray tracing technology for more
realistic Reflections visual effects 4K
Gameplay at 60 frames per second for a
more immersive Racing Experience they
also re-recorded the Sound Library to be
compatible with Windows Sonic and Dolby
Atmos so riding in a car with more turbo
will give you a much more real life
representation of what it's like in game
as for the tracks we can expect the
return of some fan favorite circuits
alongside the introduction of new
locations and challenges for us I also
love the new Dynamic time of day weather
systems and lighting tweaks to make
everything even more realistic one of
the things that I'm so excited about
with this game is this will be the most
accessible Forza Motorsport game ever
featuring blind driving assist this will
let players who are blind or low vision
use supplemental audio cues about their
position on the track something that I
have loved so much is is the way that
Microsoft really is putting
accessibility in the Forefront they've
done so much for accessibility in gaming
to let more players be able to play than
ever before I cannot tell you guys how
excited I am for this game I will
definitely be having a Forza party in my
house when it comes out I'm hoping that
I'll be the champion or maybe not it's
okay as long as I know covered like the
first maybe top three but I guess maybe
that actually might not be completely
Fair because as you're about to see I
actually got to go and sit behind the
wheel of the real life cars from the
game and it was quite an experience
[Music]
both of these cars are absolutely
stunning and seeing them up close was so
awesome for any of you car enthusiasts
out there you might already know that
the cadillacv series dot R is actually
Cadillac's third generation prototype
race car and boasts a powerful V8 engine
the design is striking and super
aggressive even just parked here in the
studio this thing just looks fast also
super exciting this car won its first
race back in May at Laguna I think one
of the big things that Drew us to this
platform was the ability to really
translate Cadillac's design language
into a high performance vehicle
we really wanted to bring something to
the fans into the racetrack that was
going to reflect Cadillac's brand like
they're racing this car like right now
basically oh yeah this is this is a race
winning uh platform right here and this
is definitely a very busy car this is
the future of the platform this is the
future of the sport and so I'm excited
for people to experience it we worked
really closely with Ford so I'm making
sure that they had an understanding of
what the Aero properties of our car like
what the power and performance curves
are like as well as what the experience
is going to be like inside of the car
providing them with math data and CAD
information so that they could build a
real authentic experience for the fans
so yeah well somebody hopping into the
game why would you tell them to choose
this car over any of the others oh like
I mean just look at this car it's
clearly the most gorgeous car that
you're ever gonna see and from a Pure
Performance and Driving Experience
perspective this is the one to go with
do you think I can get in are they are
they afraid I might take off
how do you get in here
this is just race so it's almost
it's a little dirt
all right it's official
we're getting in I gotta take my shoes
off first okay
and like I said you're really gonna sit
down there whoa yeah we're really down
there
it's like a perfect fit
okay but how can they see anything like
I can't you can't see the road can you
see the road they can see a little bit
of the road no I don't believe it
remember they have helmets on too
and their neck movement is limited as
well you can't see anything like I can't
even imagine what it's like to be behind
this wheel going nearly 200 miles an
hour down the track I could barely get
in and out of this thing and I could
even see over the steering wheel to see
the road so it was pretty scary but so
freaking cool there's no way anyone can
see out of this windshield
like there's no way is this conformed to
the Racer's butt okay which close me up
see you see you later oh man this
is so uh I'm inside the car I don't know
how anyone sees out of this vehicle oh
my goodness get me an Xbox controller
this is too intense
[Music]
the Chevrolet Corvette e-ray on the
other hand is definitely a little more
approachable it's so beautiful and with
the added electric boost it's going to
be so fun to drive virtually and in real
life the exterior is sort of a
futuristic version of the classic
Corvette aesthetic and the interior is
just as cool it feels luxurious but also
super functional so even someone like me
who is definitely not a pro race car
driver I felt very comfortable behind
the wheel
parked but I was behind the wheel I felt
I felt great so right now they're
setting up for a reveal shot of the
Corvette and my ideas I'm gonna be in
the car when they do the reveal so it's
like hi I'm driving
[Music]
so the interior in this one is so nice I
think that's one of the things that I
was a huge fan of with Corvette is you
can customize it with so many different
colors this is definitely the color that
I think I would use for myself it's
perfect the Eat Right is an electrified
sports car that combines raw power with
state-of-the-art all-wheel drive
technology it's one of the only sports
cars with two separate propulsion
systems to provide naturally aspirated
V8 power with the electrified
responsiveness of electric all-wheel
drive it is the fastest production
Corvette in history with 2.5 second zero
to 60 miles per hour and a quarter mile
in just 10.5 seconds the e-ray really is
a perfect blend of style performance and
sustainability making it a truly
remarkable addition to the world of
electrified sports cars the Corvette has
always been a staple on the racetrack
and a monster to go lab after lap but
what this car brings is that all-wheel
drive cloud or the corner immediate you
have the all-wheel drive system and I
think that's what we want people to get
out of driving this car in the game now
for anyone who doesn't know this is an
electrified Corvette so what's different
between this and a traditional one so
this is a performance electrified
variant so what we want to do is give
you both the legendary lt2 small block
V8 experience with that complementing
front axle performance so really both
systems work best in parallel especially
on a race track when you want 655
horsepower to get you down the street so
what can people expect and why should
they choose this car when they first hop
into the game you really should choose
this car because it's fast it's fun to
drive and there's nothing more fun than
getting to the throttle sooner and
letting the all-wheel drive rocket you
out of the front that's awesome I'm so
excited that's definitely going to be
one of the first cars that I try out for
sure after getting acquainted with how
each car looks and feels and nearly
getting stuck in the Cadillac I'm so
excited for this game I'm such a huge
Forza fan it is just so fun because it
really does let you experience these
cars as close to real life as possible
obviously we're standing in front of the
two new cover cars this year so how do
you guys choose which cars are going to
make the cover well these two cars in
particular are really meaningful to to
me and the team there's two halves of
Forza Motorsport there's the production
side the production cars or sports cars
and then the race cars right so this is
the first time that we're bringing a
production car and a race car and really
representing those two halves of Forza
Motorsport this time around we're really
focusing on car building as part of the
actual career mode so you'll get into
the game and it's not just about
building your car but it's about
building your career over time and it's
about building that deeper relationship
with individual Cooks so I think one of
the things that's most important I feel
like for not only the car manufacturers
but for gamers is we want these to be
authentic to the actual experience
because I know a lot of times there's no
way that any of us are actually ever
going to be behind the wheel of any of
these cars so how do you maintain that
we've got so much information CAD
drawings all of the data around the
engine weight how it's balanced and all
that so it comes through Faithfully in
the game it is a deep racing simulation
at its core our physics have gone
through complete overhaul this time
around so it is an authentic racing
simulator but we have these amazing
assists that allow anyone to jump in now
regardless of skill and just you know
enjoy the game with forza's dedication
to Precision unmatched gaming
experiences a vast array of vehicles and
state-of-the-art gaming development I am
so hyped for the 2023 edition of Forza
Motorsport and I think this is going to
be the best yet and I cannot wait to
play this was so much fun and I can't
wait for you guys to get your hands on
this game to be able to test out these
cars for yourself leave me some comments
below and I will see you guys on the
track